Esther, our costume designer,
has just been a great addition to the show.
She excelled at this spacesuit.
I pretty much looked at
every spacesuit there ever was
both in reality and onscreen.
We were creating a suit
that was feasible, that looked realistic,
you overlay all the needs of TV,
the specifics that we need—
it becomes a very complicated equation.
You up for an adventure?
Only one way to find out.
One of the biggest requests from Matt and Ben
was the actual weight of the suit.
In Season 3, the suits weighed 70 pounds
It's a lot.
Our suits are working suits.
They have to work and they have to look
like they have some function.
I was really happy with the helmet.
It looks great from all angles,
and that's a hard one to do.
Can I get one of those suits?
They're all booked.
This is the only one I got available.
From the planet Earth-wear
to our Mars habitat,
we were pushing over 500 fittings on cast.
So that's big.
It's a lot of clothes.
We need to get this thing done.
This asteroid,
it could change everything
for people back home.
The challenge for me was
to sort of set up the dynamics
that were within the written script.
We're seeing certainly a lot more color
in our professional crew.
And then when we look at the Helios crew,
there's much more utilitarian look about them
and I think it served the script very well.
We spent the time and the energy
investigating all of our choices
and making sure
they were the right choices.
I need skilled people on my side
and you are very skilled indeed.